ça commençait à marcher c'est le début
de la gloire ebit a eu pas mal d'échecs
quand même faut bien le dire aussi
comme tout le film n'a c'était quoi
parce qu'on parle toujours de na c'était
à rome un hold up à deux à l'heure 1 e
ça n'est pas évident de faire rire avec
un sujet sur les gens âgés parce que les
gens ont peur des gens âgés
ça terrorise un peu les gens et puis je
sais pas c'était peut-être un peu naïf
dans la facture et je crois que
ça n'a pas été un succès loin de là ça
m'a coûté image est due à rentrer à la
télé pour payer et ça t'a coûté aussi
pas mal d'années dans les supermarchés à
faire des signatures sinon c'était avant
c'était pas pouvoir faire le film j'ai
fait des signatures dans les
supermarchés comme on en fait tous dray
si tu n'en fais pas un jean ferrat dont
tu as bien toi mon gars c'est
enrichissant
i la lune entre les dents qu'est ce qui
s'est passé c'est la même question
ouais non ça c'est tu veux pas en parler
non plus je ne fais pas du mal comme ça
en se fixant des objectifs très très
difficile de vouloir faire plein de
choses en même temps et pierre-louis
mais je crois que c'est le secret de la
vie rue du mal non pas du tout il faut
se fixer des objectifs très haut très
haut
et puis si on loupe pas tempur commence
il ya pas de casser la gueule alors
finalement on aurait pu être curé
archevêque archevêques auraient pu être
chanteur d'opéra t'aurais pu être
journaliste aurait pu être écrivain
animateur tu es presque tamada pression
afin d'avoir gâché un immense talent
alors là je viens on expliqué mais ce
sera en tête à tête si tu veux bien un
le transfert se fait maintenant mais
prend pas mal ça suffit ok d'accord
bon allez on lance le sujet et s'il vous
plaît il ya intérêt ok les messageries
roses du minitel vous connaissez mais
savez-vous que derrière ces petits
écrans qui occupent les nuits de
certains solitaires se cachent souvent
des journalistes professionnels
officiellement reconnue est en
possession de la célèbre carte de presse
bleu blanc rouge
si vous êtes payés par une entreprise
presse vous n'êtes jamais je peux vous
montrer des petits journaux des petits
journaux qui ont été faits uniquement
pour avoir des numéros de commissions
paritaires
c'est de la presse portable d'ailleurs
c'est la place de la presse
effectivement que vous ne trouverez pas
au kiosque à une petite cinquantaine ou
100 exemplaires et puis ça suffit cela
vous respecter les normes
alors si en plus des 30 % d'impôts en
moins vous voulez un jour approcher les
stars de près au festival de cannes par
exemple
ne vous fatiguez pas à perdre des années
apprendre le métier de journaliste
professionnel
faites-vous plutôt embauché par le
minitel rose fait des pas l'or c'est de
l'info ou de l'intox
eh bien ça montre le sérieux des
journalistes aujourd'hui en france
puisque c'est totalement de l'info en
applaudi philippe
un seyant pour philippe guérin banc
philippe qui comprendra que tu
comprendras qu'on fasse pas de deux
commentaires baffie le score en l'état
s'il te plaît points pour garder aucun
mât peu dégourdi
vous et moi jacques est en train de me
[ __ ] à l'émission tu t'es où vas tu te
casses comme ça tu me fout en l'air mon
émission est ouvertement mais c'est des
questions c'est vraiment c c'est
terrible ce que tu me connais tu sais
bien que je pose de revient en copains
et puis d'un seul coup c'est c'est un
piège on dirait jamais vu mes émissions
et non mais pour les autres vues et move
ne sait ces différences quand même je
sais pas on est sur la même chaîne
sur la même chaîne fait dans mon rédac
tape sur les autres mais enfin leur jeu
ça va
voilà quoi question que je m'excuse ok
je m'excuse
bon alors gentil non ok je te prie de
m'excuser non pas comme ça ça s'est joué
je veux je te prie non simplement comme
tu le ferais au point un soir où tu
rentré très tard et où je dis à ta femme
j'ai été retenu par la télévision
j'étais retenu pour la télévision excuse
moi avoue quand même que t'es pas facile
à vivre
c'est normal sinon j'aurais fait un
autre métier
cette pointure de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible